Oh by the way,
shit,
my pants while running this morning.
Did you?
Not Hard.
Just a,
it was a shark that's coming up a hill,
had nothing left and I,
and I thought I had to fart and just Bam.
I did that the other day.
My house.
Yeah,
just a little squirt and went,
Jesus Christ heals like such a failure.
But it had some good farts before that.
That's a problem.
I got motivated because I had something from you.
You were on a roll,
some rumblers Jesus.
And it was just me.
I wish I didn't have the cover from nobody.
So I was pausing and leaning into them and
I'm at it just a little,
ah,
fuck.
Ah,
that's a shower.
But it is the ultimate failure because your job as a human is to provide for
your family and not shit your pants.
Because there's times you know like,
oh no,
I'm about to shit my pants.
There's like a,
there's a certain alarm that goes off like when you're like,
oh no,
no,
we're coaching a little too hard here.
Okay,
we've got a problem here boys.
We got a runner,
we got a runner,
we got Ron Harris.
I'm fairly key.
Keep it in there.
Calls the Yay
clamping down and it's the same exact feeling that you get is when you're trying
to hold common.
Has Domo Shit?
Yeah.
I always say one day I'm going to try Tantra.
I'm going to learn how to like completely like guys say that you can have like
an internal orgasm.
I've choke one back.
Wow.
Just got to grab the base right before impact and squeeze really hard.
But what if you cause an injury?
That's why I've only done it a couple times.
If you broke your own deck because you grabbed it too hard,
life would not be worth living.
Can you imagine that not having your Dick come anymore for the rest of your life
and knowing that you're thinking like,
this is what I can't lose.
I can't lose
embarrassing myself to a lot of guys,
like if you had to choose between being blind or having your Dick break.
Oh,
no question.
What would you say?
Give me the fucking stick and the dog.
Okay.